una mesa de billar mide un metro vamos a
dibujar de una vez las dimensiones
un metro
por 2 metros 2 metros y tiene 6 mucha
casi un total 4 en las esquinas estas 4
y 2 a la mitad de los lados de 2 metros
estas dos la bola blanca que es esta se
coloca a punto a 25 metros del lado
norte o lo que es lo mismo un cuarto de
metro de aquí acá es un cuarto de metro
y a punto a 25 metros del lado oeste
también es un cuarto de metro de aquí
acá colocada a un cuarto de metro los
ángulos que se forman en la trayectoria
de aproximación esta de aquí y en la
trayectoria de rebote esta son como la
imagen reflejada en un espejo es decir
si yo pusiera un espejo acá estas
trayectorias serían iguales como un
reflejo nos preguntan a qué distancia x
esta de acá de la esquina sureste sobre
el lado este deberá pegar la bola blanca
para que caiga en la buchaca de en medio
del lado sur los invito a que pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolverlo por su
cuenta
les doy una pista involucra triángulos
similares la clave que es que la ruta de
aproximación va a ser una imagen o
reflejo de la ruta de rebote por lo que
este ángulo de acá este ángulo será
igual a este otro ángulo por lo tanto el
ángulo complemento este de aquí
será igual a el ángulo complemento de
acá cada uno de estos ángulos naranjas
será 90 grados menos este ángulo estos
ángulos azules son ángulos congruentes y
ahora podemos construir triángulos
rectángulos vamos a poner un triángulo
rectángulo aquí a partir de dónde está
este punto y hacia acá este lado es
paralelo al lado norte y nos queda aquí
un triángulo rectángulo aquí se forma el
ángulo recto lo mismo hacemos con este
triángulo más pequeño nuestro lado va a
quedar acá y aquí se va a formar el
ángulo recto la razón por la que les
mostré que estos ángulos azules son
congruentes es para mostrar que estos
dos triángulos son similares como no
sabemos pues porque ambos tienen dos
ángulos correspondientes iguales este
ángulo de acá y este ángulo de acá por
lo tanto este tercer ángulo va a ser
igual
a su ángulo correspondiente aquí en este
triángulo si tenemos dos triángulos con
los ángulos correspondientes que son
congruentes entonces los triángulos
serán similares estos dos triángulos son
similares lo que implica que la
proporción de la longitud de los lados
correspondientes va a ser la misma
veamos que sabemos sobre estos tiempos
de ese triángulo pequeño sabemos que
este lado mide x ahora del triángulo
grande cual será esta distancia de aquí
pensemos un poco en ello sabemos que
esta distancia de aquí acá es de un
cuarto de metro y sabemos que todo este
lado mide un metro así que esta
distancia de aquí acá es de tres cuartos
de metro si esto es tres cuartos esto de
aquí es tres cuartos
de aquí la voy a marcar esta distancia
de aquí acá es tres cuartos de metro
entonces esta parte de acá de este lado
de aquí acá que corresponde a este lado
del triángulo va a ser tres cuartos
menos x que no sabemos conocemos esta
longitud de esta muchacha a esta otra
parte o esta esquina que es de un metro
porque está a la mitad de este lado que
mide dos metros así que esto mide un
metro también conocemos la distancia que
hay aquí en este lado más grande este
lado de aquí acá
bueno sabemos que de aquí todo este lado
mide 2 metros y esta parte mide 14 de
metro así que esto de aquí este lado va
a medir dos metros o lo que es lo mismo
ocho cuartos menos un cuarto de metro es
igual a siete cuartos de metro me gusta
escribir todo como fracciones impropias
porque sospecho que trabajaremos más
adelante con proporciones ya que estos
triángulos son similares y tienen la
misma proporción por ejemplo este lado
largo de arriba que no es la hipotenusa
va a ser correspondiente y congruente
con este lado de aquí abajo que es largo
y no es la hipotenusa podemos decir que
la proporción de siete cuartos
qué es lo que mide este lado del
triángulo con respecto a este lado de
aquí de un metro siete cuartos a uno va
a ser igual va a tener la misma
proporción que este lado de acá que
quedamos que son tres cuartos menos x
tres cuartos menos x con respecto a este
lado correspondiente que es x entonces
las proporciones de las dos
correspondientes son iguales ahora
despejemos x vamos a multiplicar x en
ambos lados de esta ecuación x que
multiplica todo esto y x que multiplica
a todo esto este x iba con este y aquí
nos quedan siete cuartos de x igual a
tres cuartos menos x
ahora vamos a sumar x en ambos lados
x
+ x
y que nos queda
siete cuartos de x más x o cuatro
cuartos de x más siete cuartos de x nos
va a dar once cuartos de equis y esto -
x mas x éstos se van me voy a quedar
tres cuartos y para despejar x vamos a
multiplicar ambos lados por el recíproco
de once cuartos que es lo mismo que
multiplicar por cuatro entre once en
ambos lados cuatro entre once estos se
van nos queda x igual estos se van a 311
aus de metro
a esta distancia de aquí
es
311 a vos
de metro aquí es donde debe de golpear
la bola blanca para que pueda entrar a
la buchaca que es aquí en el centro del
lado sur y con eso terminamos este
problema